scp 682 versus extremely high  temperatures could the monstrous hard to  destroy reptile finally be roasted to  death in a superheated room the  researchers at the scp foundation hope  so they locked it in a special chamber  and increased the temperature to truly  immense proportions but rather than  melting as the researchers had hoped it  developed a car pace of solid helium  which defended it from the heat even  worse was that the car pace remained in  place even as the room was reduced back  to safe temperatures when personnel were  sent in to inspect the creature the  carapace abruptly shattered and exploded  all over the room shredding everyone  nearby 682 had baited its victims inside  and gotten a little payback for the  extreme sauna session